Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Wie war noch gleich dein Name? Ja, jetzt haben wir uns mal äh ein paar Tage länger nicht gesehen als die Woche. Jetzt reißt das Programm hier langsam ein.
Ja, wir haben ja auch gerade erst mal zwei Stunden so geschnackt. Mal gucken, ob jetzt noch was für die Hörer überbleibt.
Das stimmt. Ein Missverhältnis. Normalerweise sollte man so zackig fünf Minuten Vorbereitung und ein aber so läuft's hier nicht.
Bei Lokbuchen als Politik. Da seid ihr nämlich jetzt wieder äh eingeschaltet. Ausgabe Nummer dreizehn und das Ganze an einem Freitag. Na dann schauen wir doch mal, was die Welt äh so an Themen für uns bereit hält.
Ja, Akta als Thema bleibt natürlich wir haben ja jetzt in den letzten Tagen äh gesehen, dass in Osteuropa dieses Thema irgendwie unglaublich hochgekocht ist in Polen. Riesige Demonstrationen,
wird irgendwie von den, von der größten Bürgerbewegung seit der Gründung der Solidarnosk, Solidarnosquar irgendwie neunzehnhundertachtziger Jahre, ne? Große gewerkschaftliche Bewegung in ähm in Osteuropa, Polen.
Ähm und jetzt auf einmal sieht man da Bilder äh von Polen, wo Massen in den Straßen ähm,
wild demonstrieren gegen Acta.
Das ist ein bisschen, man kratzt sich's ein bisschen am Kopf.
Wie haben die das hingekriegt, warum äh beschäftigt die dieses Thema da so sehr, ne, also ich meine, finde ich ja schön, finde ich ja gut,
ähm allerdings ist mir, es ist trotz Recherche irgendwie mir nicht so ganz klar, wie's aus welchem Grund genau dieses Thema irgendwie so bei in Polen so ins äh Markt trifft.
Ja, es ist für mich auch sehr schwer nachzuvollziehen. Äh,
Grund mangelnder Kenntnis über äh die polnische Seele. Was ich so ein bisschen gehört habe zwischen den Zeilen oder das verifizieren zu können, ist, dass ich natürlich jetzt an Akte auch viel fest macht, was nicht unbedingt mit Acta zu tun hat,
Aber ich denke, was auch hier im Wesentlichen auch so der Hintergrund ist, auch wenn er sich hier anders entfaltet,
ist, dass es einfach äh Akte ein schönes Symbol zu sein scheint für dieses. Wir können ja äh eh nichts mehr bewirken, wozu haben wir denn hier ein demokratisches System, wenn sowieso alle Verträge geheim ausgehandelt werden?
Dass es vielleicht nicht so der primäre Auslöser, aber das mag da auch eine Rolle spielen.
Gut denkbar, dass äh in Polen da die Sensibilität einfach nochmal größer ist für solche Dinge.
Denkbar, genau, ohne dass jetzt wirklich ähm.
Zu wollen, aber es scheint vor allem auch eine Wirkung zu erzielen. Die äh Proteste sind ja nicht nur, also das heißt Osteuropa, das ist im wesentlichen Polen, Tschechien, wo noch?
Slowakei, Slowenien. Aha. Da haben wir so schöne, also wir haben eigentlich aus äh hier den.
Nicht sogar noch Lettland irgendwie mit auf der Liste.
Ähm ja, das haben wir gestern, glaube ich, auch,
Lettland Actar. Ja, Lettland, auch in Lettland wird ActA ausgesetzt und die setzen alle die Ratifizierung aus, also in allen Ländern, äh die wir jetzt gerade erwähnt haben, allen Ländern gemein ist, dass sie sagen, ähm wir.
Setzen diese Ratifizierung aus, bis da mal ein bisschen Klarheit besteht. Also in Polen sagt dann sogar der Ministerpräsident, ähm bis alle Zweifel beseitigt sind, setzen wir die Ratifizierung aus in der ähm,
Slowakei, sagt der Wirtschaftsminister Jurai Miskow, ich werde kein Abkommen unterstützen, das grundlegende Menschenrechte in irgendeiner Weise einschränkt, insbesondere das Recht auf Freiheit und Privatsphäre und das den Schutz von Urhebern,
Urheberrechten über diese Rechte stellt. Also da da sind auf einmal von den Regierungen recht äh krasse Töne zu hören oder recht recht große äh,
Soll ich mal thematische Neuausrichtungen.
Na, zumindest haben sie irgendwie Respekt vor dieser Masse und
äh äh ich meine, man kann das jetzt auch erstmal als Zeit gewinnen, weil ich meine aussetzen heißt so, äh okay, alles klar, derzeit geht euch das gegen den Strich, dann warten wir einfach mal ein paar Monate, bis ihr wieder andere Sorgen habt und dann äh setzen wir das mal wieder in Kraft.
Ja
Kann man so sehen, aber jetzt zum Beispiel in Slowenien, sagt die äh Helena Dinosek Sorko, die in Japa, also die slowenische Botschafterin in Japan, die nämlich in Japan dann das ActA unterschrieben hat,
im Namen,
Sloweniens sagt, ich habe das Abkommen auf Weisung der Regierung unterzeichnet und weil es ein Teil meines Jobs ist und die entschuldigt sich dafür,
hat sich öffentlich dafür entschuldigt, dass sie diese Unterschrift geleistet hat. Das ist ja schon relativ ähm einmaliger Vorgang, dass der Botschafter sich irgendwie hinstellt und sagt, sorry
Ich habe Dienstag Vorschrift gemacht und ich habe da irgendwie nicht so drauf geachtet. Mir war die Tragweite nicht bewusst und tut mir leid, dass ich da, dass ich das Ding unterschrieben habe. Also,
Das sind schon ähm.
Jetzt frage ich mich, ob da wirklich die Einsicht vorherrscht oder ob sie einfach alle gerade nur Schiss haben, ob so einer gewissen äh revolutionären Grundstimmung, die sie da vielleicht ausmachen. Keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall wird er, ist da auf jeden also auf jeden Fall haben die Schiss klar. Ähm,
vielleicht auch von einer revolutionären Grundstimmung, aber die Maßnahme sich als Botschafter für eine geleistete Unterschrift bei einem Handelsabkommen äh
offiziells öffentlich zu entschuldigen beim eigenen,
bei der eigenen Bevölkerung ist auf jeden Fall nicht irgendwie so eine Standardmaßnahme aus deinem äh favorite Politikratgeber, den du irgendwie als Politiker auf internationalem Parkett irgendwie befolgst.
Das stimmt. Hm. Naja.
In Deutschland werden wir sehen, wie groß die Bewegung ist. Wahrscheinlich die meisten unserer Hörer werden es schon gesehen haben, wenn sie diese Folge hören, denn morgen ist in fünfzig Städten Deutschlands der große Akte-Aktionstag. Ist sogar eigentlich europaweit,
der große Akt.
Also heute ist Freitag der zehnte, nicht der dreizehnte, aber die dreizehnte Sendung am zehnten und morgen ist es dann soweit und ja ich denke auch, wir sind alle ziemlich gespannt und äh die Erwartungen hängen, glaube ich, niedrig.
Also ich äh rechne nicht unbedingt damit, dass es äh,
irgendeiner Form polnische Ausmaße hat, ja? Ähm dafür werden hier einfach noch zu viele Bahnsteigkarten gekauft bevor der Revolution,
aber ich lasse mich auch gerne überraschen.
Ja, also wir sind gespannt ähm man muss eben sehen.
Also ich sehe das ja, ich habe das ja in der letzten Folge schon gesagt, so Netz politisch intern netzpolitisches Gemeindchen, intern haben wir dieses Thema einfach ein bisschen zu lange ähm,
Wir wussten immer, dass das kommen würde und keiner hat's irgendwie so richtig äh sich einfach mal hingesetzt und das Ding aufgezogen,
und sich auf das Thema vorbereitet, sind alle so ein bisschen überrumpelt jetzt, eigentlich etwas, was wir immer vermeiden wollten, dass wir von Themen überrumpelt werden und dann,
Passiert uns das mit acta, was eigentlich seit Jahren schon aufm Schirm ist,
schon so lange auf dem Schirm ist, dass ähm Stefan Urbach, der das ja lange Zeit für die äh Piratenpartei beackert hat, als noch als,
Irgendwie schon gesagt, so ja, das liegt ja aber auf der langen Bank hier acta. Der hatte ja schon längst wieder damit aufgehört. Dieses ganze Akterding in der Piratenpartei ist ja irgendwie eingeschlafen, dieser Jahre lang her, dass er sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat,
Und äh jetzt haben wir irgendwie paar Jahre später ist das, kocht das Thema richtig hoch und ja, hat sich einfach keiner mehr mit auseinandergesetzt, ne.
Na ja, besser spät als nie. Wir werden sehen, welche Auswirkungen das hat, äh stellen wir uns mal ein bisschen in die Kälte. Ja. Morgen.
Kleinen Spaziergang.
Schön mit Schneefall vielleicht noch, mal gucken.
Aber wenn die Russen irgendwie schon bei Minus siebzehn Grad anfangen gegen Putin zu demonstrieren, dann wird man ja, wo man hier gelangweilt in Deutschland auch nochmal schafft, so wie bei Minus vier Grad. Also, eine Stunde ein Schild hochzuhalten.
Sehr gespannt auf jeden Fall. Dann Neues vom Gericht, Neues von den Gerichten. Ähm.
Anfang Februar waren die beiden Anhörungstage zur ähm vom obersten Berufungsgericht des Vereinigten Königreiches ähm bezüglich der Auslieferung,
des Herrn Assangers, der Julian Assange
und ähm da ist eigentlich nur zu festzuhalten, also die Entscheidung des Gerichtes ist äh erst später zu erwarten, aber die beiden Anhörungstore gibt's jetzt. Einzige, was man dazu sagen kann, die haben sich sehr auf äh so eine prozedurale Argumentation gestützt, ne, also wie,
also diese Abläufe, was weiß ich, darf eine Staatsanwaltschaft einen.
Internationalen Haftbefehl aussetzen und darf dann ausgeliefert werden, obwohl da keine Anklage vorliegt und so weiter. Das heißt, da, selbst wenn.
Er jetzt sich in dieser Berufung gegen die Auslieferung durchsetzen würde, wäre das eher so eine Aufhebung, echt dritter Klasse, ne. Also das wäre dann, das wäre wirklich so.
Hochformfehler und so.
Ja, also das den Sieg würde ich eigentlich gar nicht haben wollen, ja. An seiner Stelle,
könnte man sicherlich öffentlichkeitswirksam bessere.
Ja, ist die Frage, ob er das überhaupt erwarten kann, ne. Also ich meine, wenn sie schon so vorgehen, scheinen sie ja nicht sehr viel andere.
Ja
Äh Waffen äh mit sich zu führen. Das ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig. Von daher muss man sich vielleicht darauf einstellen, dass also äh,
Assange tatsächlich äh dann mal in Schweden vorläufig in Untersuchungshaft oder welcher Haft auch immer genommen wird, um dann eben dort seinen Trail zu bekommen und dann wird's äh sicherlich interessant. Ob.
Es wirklich droht, dass die Schweden ihnen in die USA ausliefern. Jedes Jahr,
sagen wir mal seine eigentliche Befürchtung ist oder zumindest seine eigentlich geäußerte Befürchtung ist. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher,
wie viel Shitstorm Schweden so ertragen kann. Ja, also bisher hatte man ja eigentlich immer ein ganz gutes Bild äh von diesem Land, aber das ja, wenn man ja hier auch gleich in der nächsten
ung haben, das scheint mir auch irgendwie alles nicht mehr so richtig gesichert zu sein. Andererseits ist so dieser Einfluss von den USA,
Wenn er sich denn wirklich in einem Maße manifestiert, dass er auch für sichtbar wird in der schwedischen Bevölkerung sehr unpopulär.
Kann man, das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Also in dem Moment, wo äh nachgewiesen wird, hier habt ihr quasi als äh auf auf Anweisung fremder Mächte gearbeitet. Das kommt da gar nicht gut an.
Was mich noch so ein bisschen weiter interessiert an diesem Fall ist,
WikiLeaks befindet sich jetzt seit so langer Zeit in der, in der Lähmung, ne?
Sie machen ja ihre Sache mit der finanziellen Blockade und das ist ja auch richtig, die besteht ja weiterhin, da ist dieses Projekt bedroht, aber dann kommen sie, wir hatten das ja schon besprochen mit ihrem Social Network irgendwie um die Ecke und also was was da irgendwie in letzter Zeit läuft und man fragt sich eigentlich, müsste es doch auch.
Sagen wir mal, eine Strategie für Wiki Leaks, die als Option auf jeden Fall dastünde wäre, zu sagen, alles klar. Ähm hier übernimmt jetzt mal jemand anders das Ruder.
Und ähm der Assange geht irgendwie seine Sache an, aber da scheint ihm vermutlich sein eigenes Ego ein bisschen im Wege zu stehen,
ähm da einfach mal jetzt wirklich zu delegieren und zu sagen, okay, lasst dieses Projekt weiterlaufen. Ähm.
Stattdessen wird bezieht er die sein seinen Prozess oder seine, was heißt sein Prozess, aber dieses Vorgehen und die Vorwürfe gegen ihn immer,
auf Wiki Leaks mit und will quasi Wiki Leaks hat wahrscheinlich Angst, dass er Wiki Leaks nicht mehr im Rücken hat, wenn,
wenn dieses Thema dann irgendwann mal richtig in dem in der Öffentlichkeit ausdiskutiert wird, dieser Vorwürfe. Ja, weil ein.
Also um das mal zusammenzufassen, mein Vorwurf würde lauten, dass er Wiki Leaks da oder die die Marke WikiLeaks,
Zu seinem eigenen Schutze, in diesem Fall nutzen möchte und gleichzeitig,
damit Wikileaks nicht unbedingt was Gutes tut, weil also Wiki League so etwas wie Wikis kann auch ohne Julian Assange funktionieren. Es könnte wahrscheinlich im Moment sogar besser funktionieren ohne ihn, aber da passiert nix.
Ja, da passiert nichts, überhaupt äh finde ich diese ganze Diskussion um alle Leaks Plattformen in den letzten zwei Jahren, insofern mega absurd, als dass es einfach de facto gar keine mehr gibt,
Also man könnte durchaus auch feststellen
dass ähm welche dunkle Macht auch immer äh die Lähmung dieser Projekte vorangetrieben hat, dass sie dann doch sehr erfolgreich gewesen ist, ja? Und äh äh es kann natürlich auch sein, na es ist wahrscheinlich auch so, dass auch,
Die Beteiligten sich selbst sehr der Lähmung hingegeben haben oder zumindest diese Lähmung doch fahrlässig in,
Kaufgenommen haben durch entsprechend fahrlässiges äh Verhalten
Ja, ich verzähle das alles gar nicht wiederholen, aber diese ganzen Streitereien, Auseinandersetzungen, dieses ganze divenhafte Getue, das war einfach nicht hilfreich und man ist halt auch schon seit längerer Zeit extrem gespalten,
Projekt, was ich wirklich sehr unpopulär benimmt, aber auf der anderen Seite eigentlich das ganze Potential zur Unterstützung hätte. Ob das jetzt am Ende noch ausreicht, weiß ich nicht,
Auch interessant, dass ob trotz verschiedenster Ankündigung so sich so recht gar kein Drittes alternatives Projekt,
manifestiert, was äh äh versucht in dem gleichen Maße vorzugehen, ob das,
mangelnder technischer Expertise liegt, äh was ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen kann oder einfach nur an mangelnder Traute da wirklich äh ranzugehen, was ich mir schon sehr viel mehr vorstellen kann.
Oder vielleicht auch einer grundsätzlich anderen Bewertung der Notwendigkeit, weil
ja nicht so, dass äh diese Leaks jetzt uneingeschränkte Unterstützung immer erfahren haben, sondern da waren auch immer viele Fragezeichen in Bezug auf äh Schutz von Privatpersonen, die da in Dokumenten erwähnt wurden, et cetera. Das waren ja alles auch durchaus Punkte, die auf der Agenda waren.
Bis die ganze Diskussion,
um die Inhalte und die Vorgehensweise vollständig zurückgetreten ist hinter diesen ganzen Auslieferungsfall und den Streit mit Open Leaks und und dieses ganze Gegockel, ja? Also es ist es ist wirklich ein Drama
Wie äh äh dieses Projekt geschafft hat so äh äh in im Schnelldurchlauf von
von unbekannt zu äh Ikone des globalen äh äh Weltwiederstandes äh hin zu so einem so einem Trauerspiel und Dauers.
Zur Seite drei, ja.
Ja, das ist äh ähm,
Kopf schütteln. Naja, wir können das eigentlich auch nur aus der Ferne begleiten. Noch ist nicht viel passiert, aber die Dinge schreiten langsam voran.
Ja, noch ganz kurz weiterer Punkt. Die Anhörung Break Lee Mannings äh,
hat da eben begonnen, da gab's ja dieses artige Dirty Two hering oder was auch immer, äh,
wenig überraschend, Menning kommt vors Militärgericht, das war ja die erste Anhörung, sollte erstmal feststellen, ob er da überhaupt landet und ähm,
da steht ihm jetzt mit seinen Vorwürfen, ist natürlich eine lange Liste, äh Unterstützung des Feindes und Geheimnisfahrrad und so weiter. Ähm,
droht ihm lebenslänglich
und selbst die Verteidigung hat ihre Strategie dahingehend geändert, dass sie nur noch zu milde aufrufen. Das heißt, äh die Verteidigung plädiert nur noch an das Gericht äh milde zu sein und äh
argumentiert damit, dass der angerichtete Schaden ja jetzt nicht so groß sei. Also auch da ähm.
Die Faktenlage ist einfach erdrückend, nicht? Es ist.
Erdrücken, klar.
Es ist einfach wirklich zu viel äh gefunden worden und Menning kann sich da eigentlich auch selber an die Nase fassen, so wie stellt es sich mir zumindest da,
Ja, also abgesehen davon, dass dass dieser ganze Chatdialog mit diesem äh mehr als nur verhinderungswürdig gewesen wäre aus seiner
weil er im Prinzip da einfach online ein Beständnis äh äh eingetippt hat in Computer und das hätte er einfach,
Für sich schon selbst realisieren können, dass das dumm war, aber.
Ein bekanntermaßen psychisch.
Na ja gut, was was ihm da bekannt war und in welchem psychischen Zustand er sich selbst befunden hat, äh ich meine, das äh machte ja schon so den Eindruck, dass er dort auch irgendwie für sich persönlich einen Befreiungsschlag versucht, um da einfach auch so ein Loch rauszukommen. Nur war das.
Auch ein unglaublicher, ein unglaublicher Druck auf einen so jungen Mann sein, äh diese Sachen da irgendwie
geliefert zu haben. Also ich kann schon verstehen, dass es ist ja wenn man die, wenn man diesen Chatdialog so liest, merkt man so richtig, wie der unaufgefordert immer wieder den Lambo anpinkt und sagt, hier ich will dir mehr erzählen, wie es aus ihm rausfließt. Und der hatte einfach
das war wahrscheinlich so ein so ein Druck, der auf ihm gelastet hat.
Ja und er hat sich dann einfach im falschen Moment den falschen ausgesucht. So, das hätte auch besser funktionieren können, wenn er da mit einem vertrauenswürdigen Hacker gesprochen hat, aber äh dieser Lambo ist da halt an der Stelle einfach,
entweder Opportunist oder tatsächlich so sehr in so einem Staatsschutzdenken verhaftet, auch das äh gibt es ja in den USA durchaus in der Hackerszene ganz stark
also nicht gilt nicht für alle, aber man hat da halt wirklich die einen und die anderen,
Er war dann halt bei den anderen. So und darüber hinaus sind halt auch die ganzen Verbindungen zu Assange äh äh weitgehend klar. Also das ist,
gibt wenig Zweifel daran, dass er halt jetzt wirklich derjenige gewesen ist, der diese Dokumente äh geholt hat und weitergeleitet hat und na ja, jetzt plädieren sie im Prinzip eigentlich nur noch auf Gnade,
inwieweit das in dem Fall vor einem Militärgericht zu erwarten ist, ich glaub da muss man sich wenig Illusion machen, also gute Prognosen würde ich Ihnen nicht,
ausstellen, auch wenn man ihm natürlich anderes wünschen würde.
Ja, in Schweden äh können wir eigentlich auch nochmal hinschauen. Da ist,
was passiert, äh weitere Gerichtsanhörungen äh wurde abschlägig beschieden, in dem Fall in dem,
gegen die Betreiber, Peter Sunde und äh drei andere, glaube ich, vier waren's, ne?
Frederik Ney, und Karl
lundströmt, äh die da die drei Gründer und dann gibt's nämlich noch den vierten mit drin, den Gottfried Smart Holm, der hatte aber schon irgendwie im November in einem abgetrennten äh Prozess sein, sein Urteil bestätigt bekommen,
Also was die Meldung ist, die erste Verurteilung gegen Pirate hat, glaube ich, schon zweitausendneun stattgefunden. Seitdem,
haben die sich offensichtlich durch die Instanzen gekämpft und jetzt hat der oberste Gerichtshof in Schweden den Berufungsantrag der genannten drei.
Abgelehnt und damit ist das Urteil vom November zweitausendzehn, wo sie nämlich in einer Berufung eine
stärkere Haftstrafe bekommen haben, glaube ich sogar, als in dem ersten Verfahren, nämlich mehrmonatige Haftstrafen, jeder. Und die Zahlung von irgendwie rund fünf Millionen Euro.
Ähm dazu wurden sie also zweitausendzehn verurteilt. Und das ist jetzt rechtskräftig, weil der Oberste Gerichtshof Schweden den Berufungsantrag abgelehnt hat.
Und ähm das heißt, die sind jetzt rechtskräftig verurteilte gesuchte.
Verbrecher. Ja und ich weiß jetzt
ganz genau, wie es da konkret äh vorangeht, aber es droht auf jeden Fall hier die Durchführung einer äh Haftstrafe, unter anderem eben auch dann für Peter Sohne, der ja eigentlich seit langer langer Zeit extrem äh ähm,
Sichtbare Größe ist, so die anderen sind eigentlich eher so weniger bekannt, aber äh,
Peter Sohne, ich meine, das ist wirklich absurd, der Typ wird äh auf auf hochkarätige Veranstaltungen geladen und zur Zukunft dieser Welt befragt.
Peter Sunde ist einer der großen Visionäre,
Was irgendwie hier als digitale Kulturrevolution stattfindet. Peter Söhne hat ja nicht, hat uns ja nicht nur den Pirat Bay gebracht, nein, er hat uns auch den Fletter gebracht.
Also in äh und wer ihnen kennt, du kennst ihn, weiß ich, ich habe ihn auch schon einige Male bei den äh Berliner Veranstaltungen getroffen.
Ein unglaublich ruhiger, gewitzter, selbstsicherer, besonnener Mensch,
Veganer äh Anti-Alkoholiker, also so alles andere als ein unbedachter, ne. Also es ist Peter Suhne ist immer immer ein anregendes Gespräch. Man.
Ich habe unglaubliche Ehrfurcht eigentlich, wenn ich wenn ich so sehe, wie was er für Visionen hat, wie gut er argumentieren kann für diese Dinge, was er für Überzeugung hat und wie treu er denen bleibt,
Und und ist und wir, dass wir es so, ich ich glaube, er hat irgendwie ein kleines äh.
Kleine ähm Anekdote am Rande ist, ich glaube Fletter ist die erste weltweite Firma mit veganen Prinzipien, ja.
Ja. Hey, die gehen immer ins veganische Restaurant, ich war ja mit ihnen essen. Und er ist, also gibt's da so Tofu-Steak und so? Ja. Hm.
Und er ist also ja und äh also echt äh völlig.
Sozialistisches Unternehmen, ja. Da kriegen alle das gleiche Geld. Ja.
Alle kriegen einen.
Also es ist echt ein ganz toller äh anregender ähm anregende Person, deren Vorträge man sich auf jeden Fall mal anschauen sollte, wenn man mal irgendwie auf YouTube oder so.
Genau, also es entzieht sich grade so ein bisschen unserer Erkenntnis äh ob das jetzt schon das letzte Wort gewesen ist, was er in seinem eigenen Blogpost nochmal in Aussicht gestellt
hat, war äh vielleicht dann auch äh zur EU zu marschieren und da den höchsten Gerichtshof mal zu befragen, ob denn das alles so sein kann.
Ähm das wird erwogen. Da gibt's meines Wissens keine Entscheidung, zumindest keine äh keine Entscheidung, die ich kennen würde.
Wenn das gemacht wird, dann, also du solltest tatsächlich auf EU-Ebene da eine Entscheidung dazu geben, dann,
hätte es wohl nicht unmittelbar eine Auswirkung auf die schwedische Gerichtsbarkeit,
ich bin kein Anwalt, ja, wir äh kennen uns nicht so gut aus, wir können das auch nur aus der Ferne äh beurteilen, von daher bleibt spannend, wir werden das Thema auf jeden Fall nochmal aufnehmen.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, also der Vorwurf gegen Pirate Base eben Beihilfe zur Urheberrechtsverletzung, ne. Das hatten wir wahrscheinlich gar nicht so,
klar erwähnt, äh also eine Seite, die damals auch noch einen Tracker für Torrence unterhalten hat, das machen sie jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr, sondern sind jetzt so eine Suchmaschine für äh,
Und das wird jetzt mit Magnet-Links eigentlich sehr dezentral geregelt.
Aber auch hier so eine ähm letztendlich dreht es sich in dieser Frage um eben diese äh Haftung für die Bereitstellung von links, ja?
Schon, wir hatten ja ein bisschen Parallelen zu äh mega Upload da gezogen, aber auch in der in der letzten Sendung schon klar gemacht, was da,
Unterschiede sind äh zwischen und äh mega Upload. Aber das so, darum geht's in dem Fall.
Ja, dann äh gab's noch ähm Aufruhr.
Ja, hier ganz in der Nähe und zwar äh wurde Karl Theodor zu Gutenberg getortet,
äh in einem Café in Berlin Friedrichshain hat sich das zugetragen. Das übrigens heute Abend ähm zu,
Ehren der Torte einen Gutenberg Karneval veranstaltet. Haben sie eine Facebook-Seite und äh haben veranstalten heute Abend in dieser Kneipe irgendwie eine eine Gutenberg-Party, weil sie irgendwie
War wohl ein sehr kleines Cafe und die haben sich irgendwie über die Medienaufmerksamkeit gefreut.
Also was ist da passiert? Äh Stefan Urbach hat sich in seiner Funktion als Mitglied des Kollektivs Telecomics mit ähm,
Gutenberg getroffen, der.
Ja jetzt.
Internet, Internetfreiheitsberater ist.
Genau, Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete.
Und wie ist es dazu gekommen, ja, vielleicht mal die Geschichte von Anfang an erklären, Gutenberg wurde also
berufender äh Internet Consultant zu sein, Internetfreiheits Consultant und es fand sich dann kurz darauf als Reaktion auf der Seite von Telecomics, Telecomics sind die.
Die damals als in äh in Nordafrika das Internet abgeschaltet wurde, Modem Einwahlknoten bereitgestellt haben, in Deutschland.
Damals vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr. Ähm ziemlich genau ein Jahr her sogar. Ähm,
und dann quasi das Internet wieder gebracht haben, indem sie den Leuten fern verbinden, also für für teure Ferngesprächverbindungen Möglichkeit gegeben haben, ins Internet zu kommen.
Ähm dieses Grüppchen hat also dann auf seiner Webseite,
einen offenen Brief an Gottenberg geschrieben und gesagt, wir würden uns mal gerne mit ihnen unterhalten.
Und ähm soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, hat Stefan Urbach diesen Brief jetzt nicht unbedingt selber geschrieben. Bekam aber dann.
Quasi den Zuschlag.
Ein Anruf von Gutenberg, der sagte, Mensch hier, lass mal treffen.
Und ähm Stefan hat das dann auch, ja, publik gemacht, hat das irgendwie sofort getwittert und gesagt, hier äh Gutenberg hat sich bei mir gemeldet, will sich mit mir treffen, wir treffen uns irgendwie Anfang Februar,
Und in dem Moment war natürlich für Stefan Urbach so eine Falle zugeschnappt, weil er hätte jetzt entweder sagen können,
Ich lehne das ab, mich mit ihnen zu unterhalten und hätte damit Telekomics,
sage ich mal, dauerhaft von jeglicher Zusammenarbeit mit der EU finanzieller Unterstützung von der EU und jeglicher politischer Glaubwürdigkeit.
Abgeschnitten, weil man gesagt hätte
Telekomics, die Jungs so, wir gehen zu euch hin, wollen uns mit euch unterhalten und ihr lehnt ab, was seid ihr denn für ein Internetfreiheitskollektiv, ja, wenn ihr nicht, wenn ihr nicht die Gelegenheit wahrnehmt, äh euch auf EU-Ebene mit unseren Beratern zu treffen,
Das heißt, die Option stand eigentlich nicht wirklich äh ständig wirklich zur Debatte. Andererseits musste er jetzt irgendwie als Vertreter der deutschen Netzgemeinde TM,
sich zum Steigbügel für Gurtenberg machen.
Bei der Planung dessen politischen Comebacks, weil nichts anderes ist ja diese Tätigkeit, das ist der erste Schritt eines Comebacks und es wird auch langfristig.
Als ein solcher in die äh Geschichte seiner Kanzlerschaft eingehen.
Man könnte auch von der Beschäftigungsmaßnahme sprechen, ja, also ich will das gar nicht so überhöhen.
Wie auch immer, er muss ähm er muss quasi für die Glaubwürdigkeitsgurtenbergs herhalten in dem Fall. Und was natürlich dann passiert, Stefan Urbach ist auch Mitglied der Piratenpartei.
Und äh dort auch beschäftigt und man lernt jetzt gerade wieder seine.
Seine Jobdescription hat sich da jetzt gerade wieder geändert. Ähm,
Auf jeden Fall sagen natürlich dann die Piraten, was ist denn hier los? Eines unserer prominenteren Mitglieder macht auf einmal Hinterzimmergespräche mit äh Gurtenberg.
Denn dieses Treffen sollte ja unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit stattfinden und da hat sich dann ein länger ein mehrtwöchiger äh,
Sturm der Enterüstung, um mal das Wort Shitstorm nicht so zu strapazieren gegen ihn ähm ergossen. Was also da äh,
Was sich also darauf bezog, dass er sich da trifft und in welcher Funktion er es tut und er musste immer klarstellen, dass er das als Telekommix macht und nicht als Piratenpartei und ähm sehr hitzige Debatte,
Und dann hat jetzt eben irgendwann in der letzten Woche dieses Treffen tatsächlich stattgefunden.
Und wie auch immer es passiert sein mag, haben also es war ja eigentlich dieser Ort war nicht öffentlich bekannt.
Irgendwie muss wohl spontan doch bestimmten Menschen mitgeteilt worden sein, wo er sich befand, vermutlich irgendwie dadurch, dass jemand im Cafe Gutenberg erkannt hat oder wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall sitzt in einem dann veröffentlichten Video
der Gutenberg da in diesem Cafe oder in dieser Kneipe und kriegt eine Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte ins Gesicht gedrückt.
Das Video ist irgendwie unterlegt mit so Musik, hätte ich dich heute erwartet, hätte ich Kuchen da.
Oh man.
Und ähm ja Stefan Urbach äußerte sich dann dazu, dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt notwendig gewesen wäre. Stand natürlich dann auch erstmal unter Verdacht irgendwie an der Aktion beteiligt zu sein.
Ja, das ist äh natürlich nachvollziehbar, ne?
Aber äh das ist wohl offensichtlich nicht der Fall gewesen, ähm weil er sich ja auch hat die Aktion ja dann auch kritisiert.
Ähm.
Ansonsten ist was zu sagen, diese Torte, die er offensichtlich in großer Eile besorgt wurde, hatte einen harten Kern und eignete sich daher nur bedingt zum Torten, wenn man sich also andere Videos anschaut mit voll voll Sahnetorten.
So die Bill Gates-Torte zum Beispiel.
Also das war eine sehr schöne Torte. Also die diese Bill Gates-Torte, die hat auf jeden Fall sehr viel besser gesessen als die bei Guntenberg.
Das war ja aber auch der äh Großmeister des des Sahnetorten schmeißens.
Der das gemacht hat. Ähm wie hieß denn der Vogel noch mal? Der hat ja diverse Leute tortiert. Also das ist ja äh nicht kein Einzelfall gewesen, ne. Äh das habe ich jetzt gerade mal nicht.
Machst du das Tor?
Muss ich gleich nochmal nachschlagen. Das ist schon äh so lange her. Also das Video ist natürlich omnipräsent, ne? Hier ist denn dieser Freak.
Also vielleicht noch diese Aktion, dass äh das Gutenberg da getortet wurde, ähm wurde dann durchaus von einigen Leuten auch äh irgendwie sehr kritisch gesehen.
Ähm ich denke mal, äh es ist niemand zu Schaden gekommen und ähm,
insofern ist das Decke äh sehe ich das noch und im Rahmen von einer politischen Aktion und er hat's ja auch erstaunlich äh gut,
Er hat dann irgendwie auf Facebook äh wohl irgendwie geschrieben, er hätte beim nächsten Mal gerne eine Käse-Sahne-Torte,
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass er die auch dann kriegen wird.
Ja, also ich denke, das Gegenteil ist hier erreicht worden. Ja, also da äh haben sich, glaube ich, ein paar Leute nicht unbedingt einen Gefallen getan, ne? Äh weil, ich glaube, der Punkt,
der fortgesetzten Abstrafung äh für ihn war eigentlich äh,
Das war einfach abgeschlossen soweit das Kapitel, ja. Und jetzt da noch drauf zu hauen, ich meine, da kann man äh,
die ähm wie soll ich sagen, Bestätigung seiner äh Existenz durch irgendwelche Aktivitäten äh äh lamentieren, ja, das war jetzt kein öffentlicher Auftritt und an der Stelle finde ich das eigentlich auch.
Also ich will das jetzt nicht irgendwie verdammen oder so, aber ich find's unklug, weil ich finde nicht, nicht, dass es äh dass es jetzt irgendwie groß was gebracht hat. Man hatte auch nicht so den Eindruck, dass das so im Netz auf einmal,
mit großer Begeisterung aufgenommen wurde, vielleicht auch schon deshalb, weil ja, weil's eben mit konkret in dem Moment auch wirklich in so einem Moment war,
den man zwar kritisch sehen kann, diese Auseinandersetzung, aber an der Stelle reden wir jetzt mal echt auch über Realpolitik und reden wir auch wirklich um konkrete Fortschritte. Man kann sich natürlich lange Zeit darüber
beklagen, wie sehr man ignoriert wird und und so weiter und die Politik macht ja was sie will, ja? Und,
Okay, ich kann ja verstehen, dass man ja jetzt nicht besonders glücklich ist, dass man jetzt ausgerechnet.
Ihn da vor die Nase gesetzt bekommt, ja? Aber ich fand das in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon wieder lustig, ja? Also das, ja, das.
Sieh's mal andersrum. Ja, dieses hätte sich das Gutenberg träumen lassen, noch vor einem Jahr,
dass er irgendwann mal gezwungen sein wird,
für diese Nerds, die ihn letzten Endes ausm ausm Amt gehoben haben durch ihre Vicky und Online-Aktivitäten, diese ganze Vernetzung und diesen ganzen äh äh Netzsturm, mit dem er sicherlich nie so gerechnet hat,
dass dass er jetzt auf einmal der, der, der, der Dienstbote ist, der da äh durch die Gegend geschickt wird, um irgendwie zuzusehen, wie man die unterstützen kann und den irgendwie Kohle bringen kann. Das finde ich eigentlich schon.
Finde ich eigentlich schon ganz ganz lustig so, ja und und da dann irgendwie noch draufzuschlagen, das weiß ich nicht, also da da tritt man einfach nur die, die schon am Boden liegen und das ist keine Ahnung. Also mich, mich ich mir ist es einfach nicht gelungen, mich da jetzt besonders drüber zu freuen oder das irgendwie
toll oder als notwendig äh anzusehen.
Also deswegen.
Wie gesagt, so kann man, ist, ist auf jeden Fall eine zwiespältige Aktion. Ähm was, weshalb ist mir so wichtig war, diesen Rahmen da nochmal ähm,
Darzustellen, weil das das Stefan Obachter in so einer, in so einer Situation war, in der er eigentlich jede Option, die er hatte.
Eine schlechte. Ja, also wie gesagt, nicht mit guten Back reden, wäre nicht möglich gewesen, mit Gurtenberg reden war äh ein Problem und.
Schon, dass es.
Dass dieser, dass diese Wirkung auch Gottenberg bekannt war und dass er nicht mit Telekomics hätte sprechen äh, dass er nicht auf die Idee gekommen wäre, mit denen zu sprechen, wenn sie nicht so, wenn sie nicht diesen diesen offenen Brief geschrieben hätten, ja?
Und dass das klar war, dass dann dass da ein Keil getrieben wird.
Und das dann exempel statuiert wird, ja? Ich gehe hin und treffe mich Stefan Urbach. Ich
nehmen mir eine Person heraus, gerade mit Telecomics, die ja äh eine relativ bedingungslose
oder eine absolut bedingungslose Idee von von Netzfreiheit haben, die machen ja auch irgendwie, die stellen ja Miros von irgendwie syrischen Webseiten zur Verfügung, die gerade von enorm bis gede-Dos werden, also sie sind,
sehr äh absolut inhaltsneutral.
Ja, ich denke, es ist aber jetzt auch ein bisschen vermessen. Äh ich will hier gar nicht den großen Gutenbergverteidiger spielen, aber ich ich finde das jetzt einfach,
ein bisschen vermessen, pauschal jetzt ihm oder der EU, dieser Neligrüß oder so äh grundsätzlich zu unterstellen, sie hätten an dieser Unterstützung kein Interesse. Ja, also ich meine, äh immerhin,
müssen sie das ernst nehmen. Ich meine, ich hätte mir auch gut vorstellen können, dass man da offene Briefe schreibt und nur bei die care the shit,
Ja, jetzt ist das schon so, dass du eben sowas schreibst und dann dann gibt es sogar eine Reaktion,
darüber dann noch groß aufzuregen. Nur weil einem jetzt der Bote gerade nicht mal passt, weil er halt rein zufällig und es ist in gewisser Hinsicht Zufall, ja? Sie hätte er auch irgendjemand anders nehmen können, dann wäre diese ganze.
Da hätte dann niemand drüber geredet, verstehst du? Dann so, ah okay, jetzt kommt die EU und will Telecomics unterstützen, schön.
Ja, dann haben sie hier irgend so einen belgischen Außenhändler geschickt und, und, und, und niemand hätte es interessiert. Aber nur, weil jetzt äh äh da dieser eine freie Berater, gerade in Deutschland halt irgendwie gerade mal die Arschkarte des Jahres gezogen hat, passt es auf einmal nicht. Also das
ist mir einfach zu einfach, verstehst du? Es ist mir einfach äh an der Stelle einfach.
Aber so so will ich die Situation halt auch nicht interpretieren. Also wenn du sagst, äh
also der der Berater zieht die Arschkarte des Jahres. Wir haben ja hier auch noch andere äh wir haben ja hier noch eine andere Folge bei Lokbuch-Netzpolitik gehabt, wo wir äh die Situation, dass Gutenberg da jetzt auf einmal in dieser Position ist, auch äh doch etwas
anders bewertet haben, da viel übrigens sogar doch von mir der Satz wahrscheinlich trifft er sich demnächst noch mit Telekomics. Ja, was dann auch tatsächlich ja passiert ist. Ähm.
Ja gut, ich meine,
die In-Augoration als solche das da haben wir uns äh haben wir dann Stellung bezogen und davon habe ich ja auch gar nichts abzuziehen, aber irgendwann muss man dann diese Realität auch einfach mal akzeptieren,
dass man das jetzt Scheiße findet oder oder oder ein Treppenwitz der Geschichte oder was auch immer, fein so, aber soll's jetzt vorangehen oder nicht? Das ist eigentlich alles, was ich sagen will.
Aber da, das ist ja, ich meine, diese Aktion ist ja unabhängig davon, von jetzt, was auch mit Telekom nichts passiert ist. Ähm das ist ja davon,
Also das bleibt dem ja unbenommen,
immer so schön sagt. Ähm das heißt, dass das läuft und nebenbei hat er eben nochmal eine Torte ins Gesicht bekommen.
Ist okay und wir werden sehen, die haben ja angekündigt, dass sie das jetzt jedes Mal machen wollen, wenn Gutenberg irgendwo äh an seinem politischen Comeback arbeitet. Und wir werden sehen, ob sie das machen oder nicht. Ich habe auch, wie gesagt, das waren,
irgendwie enorm ist und,
irgendwie Konditoren oder so nannten, die digitalen Konditoren und haben das irgendwie gemacht. Gut, haben sie gemacht und ähm.
Finde ich jetzt, also ich ich finde die Aktion nicht wichtig genug oder nicht, nicht kräftig genug, als dass das als dass ich sie jetzt ernsthaft strategisch kritisieren würde,
So, dass, also das, das war mir einfach so wichtig. Haben sie gemacht. Fand ich auch in dem Moment ganz das Video fand ich ganz lustig. Gut, wer kriegte Torte ins Gesicht? Dann denkt man sich irgendwie, ja ist ein bisschen wenig dran packen geblieben.
Ich ich versank so ein bisschen in mir und versetzte mich einfach in die Situation von dem Stefan Urbach. Ja, der was weiß ich, vielleicht schon eine halbe Stunde in dem Moment einfach versucht hat,
Seriös,
aufzutreten und danach einfach zwangsläufig in Verdacht gerät, damit irgendwas zu tun zu haben. Das war einfach das Erste, was mir durch den Kopf ging. Und da dachte ich mir so,
Ich hätte da jetzt nicht sitzen wollen. Also das wäre mir echt peinlich gewesen in dem Moment.
Ja, aber also der hatte damit nix zu tun, ne? Umso.
Na ja, klar, aber der Verdacht, weiß ich nicht, ob man den so ausgeräumt bekommt. Ist halt so. Na ja, wie auch immer.
Denke, ich meine irgendwie gelesen zu haben, in irgendeiner Meldung, dass die ähm,
Die Angreifer, diese digitalen äh in irgendeinem Interview auch selber gesagt haben, dass sie dass sie es nicht von ihm wissen.
Also dass sie dass dass sie keine Informationen von Stefan Obachern. Ich meine, der hat das absolut geheim gehalten, wo er sich trifft und wann, ne? Also er hat das wirklich das war irgendwie Erd.
Die Hintergründe kenne ich nicht, aber das das war einfach mein Gefühl in dem Moment.
Na gut, wir können das abschließen. Der äh äh Tortenwerfer, wo man äh lernen kann, welche Torte man zu kaufen hat, heißt übrigens Noel äh Gooddoin und ist ein ähm belgischer
Autor und Kritiker und der hat also nicht nur Bill Gates äh totiert, sondern der hat irgendwie auch Sarkosi und diversen anderen äh Personen, also irgendwie, was weiß ich,
waren Dutzend da äh schon regelmäßig äh irgendwie passender,
eine tatklassig äh nimmt man da wohl hier Schlagsahne und weißer Biskuit äh Kuchen.
Das französische Wort für eine Torte ist ein eine Entertain. Tarcht die Torte unter Tag.
Tortierung.
Ja, also oh, der hat aber eine lange Liste. Meine Güte, der ist fleißig, der junge Mann.
Ja, ja, das ist, wieso ich so sagte, der ist halt einfach mal die Referenz, was das Tortenwerfen betrifft.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, also diese Aktion des Tortenwerfens, also was die Symbolik des Tortenwerfens, finde ich.
Vielleicht deswegen auch meine meine Sympathie für diese Aktion. Die Symbolik des Tortenwerfens finde ich also als als politische Ausdrucksform das Tortenwerfen finde ich eigentlich eine,
eine ziemlich ähm feine. Also so dieses,
also einfach so knallt einmal eine Torte ins Gesicht. Das ist halt so eine, ich meine, es ist keine Körperverletzung. Äh es ist äh es ist irgendwie da da so.
Und jeder weiß, was gemeint ist, so und dieses dieses kleine Torte statt vieler Worte, was ja auch das äh der Titel dieses dieses Videos ist, was da veröffentlicht wurde. Das ist das finde ich als als politisches Statement,
durchaus sehr ähm.
Sehr wirkungsvoll, ja? Und ähm ich, also ich persönlich hätte nichts dagegen, wenn das jetzt einfach mal wieder ein bisschen öfter passieren würde, ja? Weil ich also so,
Ich finde diese diese Aktion, zack, Torte, butsch, ähm also da sehe ich einfach witzig.
Sieht schon blasser aus.
Werdet ihr irgendwie anguckst wie Bill Gates da irgendwie den Weg da geht.
Und dann kann man sich stundenlang angucken.
Insofern.
Also auch äh es gab nämlich dann auch einige, die dann dieses Jahr hier äh bösartig gemeine Aktion und Angriffe auf diese Person und so. Und da finde ich, muss man bei der Bewertung einer Tortung durchaus mal wieder die Kirche im Dorf lassen, so der
ist keine schwerwiegende Verletzung. Das ist lustig. Ja, äh das sieht witzig aus. Also ähm.
Also ähm bloß Schwarzwälder Kirsch sollte man nicht nehmen.
Schwarzwälderkirsch, offensichtlich, das haben jetzt echt ein paar äh Leute gelernt zur Schwarzwälderkirche ist dafür nicht geeignet.
Wikipedia lesen.
Ja, es gibt ich habe dann auch nachher noch gesehen, es gibt ja durchaus Anleitungen dazu, ne, wo dann eben gesagt wird, wie man mit seiner Torte umgehen muss.
Aber insgesamt also hier dieser Noelgoin, wenn ich mir die Liste anschaue, also ich meine, der wird ein ordentliches Büchlein haben, wo er so ein ordentliches Tagebuch versagt, so äh wen er da alles
äh getortet hat. So ich stelle mir das dann auch so vor, wie man dann irgendwie,
irgendwohin anreist, ne? Also mehr längeren Flugchecks dann so im Hotel ein, nimmst dir extra ein Apartment, wo du eine Küche hast, damit du eine Torte machen kannst und dann, weiß ich, beschäftigst du dich ein paar Stunden, damit irgendwie diese Torte zu machen, dann musst du die irgendwo reinschmieren, schwul, dann patscht du dich irgendwie mal ins Gesicht und dann
äh hast du deine fünf Minuten Rum?
Finde ich schon, also.
Ja, passt schon.
Diese harsche Kritik am am Torten als Aktionsform, finde ich ihn auf jeden Fall nicht angebracht.
Na gut, wie auch immer. Logbuch Netzpolitik, äh euer Expertenradio zum Thema und Tattoo,
ähm schließt damit ab.
Bis zur nächsten Woche und äh dann gucken wir mal, was rausgekommen ist bei der Revolution.
Nächste Woche machen wir nicht.
Stimmt, wir machen eine Woche Pause. Bis bald. Bis bald. Ciao, ciao.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.